president biden is not revealing what he
plans to say to russian leader vladimir
putin when the two meet in geneva next
week
the president declined to get specific
as he met with world leaders at the g7
summit
in england white house correspondent
peter ducey is traveling with the
president in cornwall tonight
not cornwall cornwall good evening peter
good evening from cornwall brett and
president biden just left
dinner at one of the world's largest
greenhouses after
nearly three hours with his friends in
the group of
seven he hasn't had much to say on
camera today
one day closer to that one on one with
vladimir putin
mr president what's your message to
putin
i'll tell you after i deliver it but
first so-called
family photos in front of one of the
world's largest greenhouses eden place
and one of the world's most beautiful
places carbus bay
the french president got as touchy with
biden as anyone in the covet 19 era
a scene we don't expect to see repeated
at next week's summit with putin
we're not seeking conflict with russia
we want a stable particular
predictable relationship what does
russia want
to help iran get better at spying
launching a russian-made spy
satellite with a high-res camera to
better track military targets according
to the washington post
republican senator mitt romney says call
this what it is
russia is giving a state sponsor of
terrorism
an advanced tech platform that it will
use to bring more destabilization
to the middle east we've got a
re-emerging russia
who wants to develop their own sphere of
influence expectations are high
at time magazine where the president is
pictured staring putin down
through aviator sunglasses but critics
accuse biden of looking
the other way we've had two cyber
attacks on our economy
coming from russian territory by russian
organizations
i think are given a pass by the russian
government the white house claims
that's on the agenda the russian
government is not responsible
for these hacks that we've seen over the
last few months but they are absolutely
accountable
for the actions of malign actors the
group of seven has
other priorities first though discussing
a global minimum tax of 15 percent
to make sure the recovery from covet 19
is fair worldwide
and in all things there is a major focus
on climate
and gender equality we're building back
better
together and building that greener
and building farah and building back
more
equal and uh more
in in a more gender neutral and perhaps
like a more feminine way
as a way of saying thanks for being a
good host president biden gave prime
minister johnson
a six thousand dollar bicycle from a
shop in philadelphia and as a way of
saying
thanks for coming johnson gifted biden a
framed
photo of frederick douglass that the
times of london reports johnson staffers
printed out after first finding it on
wikipedia
brett wow
he knows how to shop for gifts peter
thank you
we'll follow this trip european hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else